à l'issue de cette audience toute une
gamme x de commerce de fort de france
qui se tenait ce matin à huis clos et en
chambre du conseil
les salariés regroupés autour de
l'avocat ne cachent pas leur déception
ils espéraient que la mise en
redressement judiciaire de la clinique
sainte-marie géré par le groupe kapa
santé soient annoncés immédiatement
le personnel est très déçus parce qu'on
voit c'est qu'aujourd'hui on allait
finir avec ça et on constate qu'il faut
des donateurs d'accord et là encore
aujourd'hui on parmi nos collègues
on a eu des chèques qui ont été rejetées
on a été payé par chèque ce mois ci et a
eu d'échec a été rejetée par là bas donc
vous voyez dans quelle situation nous le
personnel de la clinique sainte marie on
se met maintenant à faire du bénévolat
l'atrix est pagne enquête diligentée par
le parquet de fort-de-france où est elle
précipité cette demande en redressement
judiciaire
il est clair que du côté des salariés
les demandes sont claires et précises ce
qu'on demandait les salariés c'est
premièrement qu'une expertise sur les
comptes et deuxièmement qu'on sache
assez rapidement quelle est la position
du groupe kapa nouveaux cas pas à la
volonté ce qui est son droit de
continuer l'activité mais il doit
présenter un plan de continuation
nous voulons connaître le plan de
continuation et la réalité de ce que
sera fait puisqu'il faut bien comprendre
que ça fait des années que cap a fait
des promesses de rénovation de remise en
état de la clinique et qui ne sont
jamais respectées
des représentants du groupe kapa santé
qui estime qu'il n'avait pas le choix
car la fermeture de la maternité imposé
par la hes et la masse salariale trop
importante ont engendré de déficit de
plusieurs millions d'euros
mais il ya un plan social certes mais ça
ce sera déterminé avec l'administrateur
judiciaire qui va juger selon les
éléments qu'il aura sous la main
si nous allons faire un plan social ou
pas moi je pense en tant que responsable
de la clinique que il nous faudra de
toutes les façons passer à un écrémage
la masse salariale les salariés
annoncent qu'ils se battront jusqu'au
bout pour conserver leur emploi
le 14 septembre prochain le tribunal
mixte de commerce de fort de france 2
fera ou pas se prononcer sous
l'ouverture d'une procédure de
redressement judiciaire